welcome back to fox news primetime
we've obtained new images out of chicago
from over the weekend
please be advised some may find what
we're about to show you
graphic thousands of young people
gathered for a three-day
music festival without masks look at
them
didn't they hear joe biden's dire
warning about a second dark winter
many of those who claim to follow the
science became very upset at this site
they don't like to see people outside
having fun they want you to believe
these concert goers are in grave danger
and that might be true
they are in chicago after all last month
the city saw 105 murders three times the
amount of coveted deaths
in washington d.c murders also surpassed
kova deaths by a near three to one ratio
in july
despite these numbers the media and
elected officials
are seemingly still trying to figure out
how to flatten the curve
instead of addressing the violent crime
pandemic plaguing inner cities
tim poole hosts the tim cast irl podcast
and he joins me now tim it's good to see
you
thanks for having me ben you know this
level of hypocrisy that we see
from the leaders of america's inner
cities
it it's audacious in a way that i really
have i mean it's like nothing i've seen
before it's as if they
imagine that the american people are
just too stupid to pay any attention
to the level of hypocrisy and the level
of government's failure
to address the problems that are clearly
impacting our communities
what do you think is going on here i i i
honestly have no idea
you know having grown up in chicago see
i i've personally witnessed the gun
violence
i'm wondering why after my entire life
they've not been able to solve it they
seem to just keep doubling down
but when it comes to the coveted
restrictions our leaders the mayors
the governors we see them flaunting the
rules they don't wear masks they tell
everyone else to
the funniest thing about chicago is
they're warning us that the delta
variant is on the rise
we gotta we gotta bunker down and make
sure we slow the spread
but only after we can make tens of
millions from our big rock concerts at
the same time
they come out and tell us that all the
black lives matter protests
weren't spreading covet and all the
right-wing lockdown protests were
i can't believe people fall for these
narratives and it kind of breaks my
heart to see
well it really is frustrating on a
number of different levels but
for me in particular i mean i know
people who have experienced
all manner of different criminal
situations in washington d.c
that took hours to get responses i'm
sure that you saw that footage
and in fact i know you talked about it
on your podcast recently from the d.c
police chief talking about
how far behind he is when it comes to
the level of manpower that he needs
in order to maintain a safe city that to
me seems to be
a scandal that everyone should be
talking about and instead we're just
debating
about whether you need to wear a mask
and what the penalties should be if you
don't
it's a perfect uh scapegoat it's a
perfect excuse a perfect distraction
there's there's so many places in this
in our country that have had escalating
crime and violence especially over the
past year
we've had untold riots and violence and
and political terror on small businesses
and then as soon as the bad news comes
that could negatively impact
their their political world their their
the democratic party all of a sudden
they got to shift everything back to the
argument about the pandemic
and they've got allies in media who
allow them to do it they don't they
don't challenge them on these things
very often if at all and often they
translate on their behalf and explain
what they're really doing and why
my favorite is this study came out of a
colorado i believe
one of the universities showing that
actually the black lives matter protests
reduced
may have reduced the spread of covid as
if we're supposed to believe that while
our cities are being attacked and some
small business
businesses are being destroyed now we're
seeing escalating crime
and we're not getting a conversation
about it i think people on the right
conservatives
people disaffected liberals need to take
control of the narrative
and start asking these questions and not
let them pull the conversation back
we've got a vaccine they've they've gone
and talked about how effective it is and
how it's working it's fantastic
and we're gonna get those vaccination
numbers up okay then why are you coming
out with more restrictions
more lockdowns why are you trying to act
like everyone's got to stay home
meanwhile you get to do whatever you
want tim you
are someone who has been at the front
end of media innovation over the past
several years you've
created really an alternate way for
people to get some of this information
that is never really talked about
within the dominant forces of corporate
media it seems to me that you
and people like you have a critical role
in shifting this conversation to
what really matters what are some of the
ways that people who may not have your
platform but who want to try to
shift that narrative as you say how can
they get involved how can they
share information that cuts across and
actually highlights the things that
matter
as opposed to going on with this
corporate narrative
well it's hard because we've got the
issue of big tech censorship
we see cancel culture that many on the
left deny but there are
regular people with small accounts
trying to express themselves they'll say
something like learn to code and get
banned on twitter
but i really do think you need you need
a critical mass of people
stepping up and expressing themselves
and i understand it's very difficult you
know for people who have families and
children they're trying to just get
through this to make sure their kids
will have a better future will be able
to have food to eat and have a job to
support their families
but i really do believe that if
everybody who opposed you know the
wokeness the hypocrisy from from you
know our leaders
if they did speak up and they were brave
then i think we would see a dramatic and
immediate change
you have to go out and make that stand
though take that risk
in order to shift the narrative tim
thanks for joining me
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else